hello and welcome to this video I don't
know what this works really so is just a
try
probably it works to some extent of she
listening to this and I'm trying to make
a video from my a vacation spot here in
Slovenia
I've taken my notebook with me which is
usually just the one device I use form
yet doing some chest content but I'm not
at home for chest base and so on but I
never done any video recordings on it
and so forth for a while and I've done
something years ago with it for video
but I completely reset the notebook some
weeks ago because it was getting slower
and slower so I needed to do something
anyway um I'm happy to hear your
feedback if this is a yeah how this is
working is it decent quality or is it
absolutely terrible would be good to
know because if it is if it is okay I
will definitely do more videos now
during the holiday time I've got some
time off ously the vacation and it's
totally fine to do video per day but I
only want to make it if it's really am
is usable and looks looks fine okay in
this game against
advocaat 38 Ross and we have a Dutch
type of position and you can grab this
pawn and you saw that yeah
on the other hand my position is not
that bad I think I can jump in here
and while the rooks here didn't have
many squares so we had to take it maybe
not had to take it but almost okay so
here yeah I think this actually
I mean he's not easily playing a six and
getting a passer my bishop here is nice
on will be nice on deform no the apron
is singing and how to see a hand of this
situation I don't quite know yeah here
at 92 to watch out for it so the ape
horn looks like it should drop
yeah my main goal with this video is to
test this whole thing so I'm not I mean
I don't want to play nonsense little bit
I don't care so much about the result
yet it's a late join and um sometimes
I'm trying to win this syllabi berserk
in every single game which is fun but
maybe not what I want to try to do now
today I also want to check the whole
thing it is said to work yeah I mean the
internet connection here isn't fantastic
but it seems to be perfectly fine to do
this what I cannot do is a live stream I
tried this a bit but the upstream is
just too slow I mean making a video and
uploading it later via YouTube is fine
because you just then have to be a
little bit patient until the recording
is done but generally speaking the
internet connection is not quick enough
for streaming so ultimately this pawn
would be a problem I don't see how we
cover it Knight a5 looks extremely wacky
mmm I have just two b5 then probably you
can move but the night hang so there is
no brilliant discovery by this maybe
maybe this is any brilliant is brilliant
it's a lot but maybe it's a move you
will take it to
okay so here I'm doubling on the seventh
h7 is tough to cover can only do it with
the rook we just covered so what's going
on here if I go look here
h4 kingi fold
yeah that's made up it's not made
actually he can go f4
it should win Mississippi it's not a
maid I don't see a meal made at least
it's better to mate I mean first of all
it's the end of the game but it's also
just quicker game continue sir you never
know where you might blunder stuff hood
it is a quite difficult choice for
others okay so I won this ultimately but
I'm really far far behind really far
behind so I hope this works yeah I mean
I did a brief test the Crammer camera
the webcam looks weird it's maybe
something I can improve I never used the
camera I think on this notebook I can't
remember really so well it's not a super
important point shall i beserk you know
let's just play some games and at the
end again as I said to the feedback is
most important to me this is actually
worth doing yeah funny sideline I played
him it's a bit of a kink kinks what to
the Lancers and Queens gambit accepted
with reversed colors and white is quite
active him okay this is a very nice
position now where you will be able to
torch your black forever okay so here
Knight b6 is already pretty strong with
what is your next move
yeah that doesn't work so this is except
a funny case where and that's forcing
move wasn't was a good good thing to do
however it's funny I just recognize I
moved the look and he will take f3 he
would win b6 back which is well I would
assume unplanned but funny it works okay
so I can go here though and now nightly
for me is a slightly shaky where I'm
trying here yeah okay probably all the
way back I got this heaven now as a
square and so if the bishop moves I know
where to go it is it's shaking okay it's
a text should be for covers the night
but this is the most obvious thing to do
yeah so all this is covered that's
important I wonder if I should trade or
keep one on the board probably trading
makes it easier to play probably
ninety-two I will kill you one night and
freeze and this is could share my kings
now covering the entry squares and I
have good chances to at the end will be
seven so with a six I'm sorry
we should see five next the look has
snow good square really and b5 will drop
as well okay that's very easy one just
push the pause home okay okay now a
result yeah maybe I can get some decent
position at the end and the in the
overall standings but again it's not
that important hmm the purely chess
performance here like HF and the
connection everything it's really ok
yeah totally fine with this okay let's
go if I play the toilet ok this is also
possible maybe we can work with a little
trick I can you react this to it but
it's that good
I can go Queen b3 here right it takes
before I check f7 Queen e6 check and I'm
attacking d7 it looks like I'm winning a
pawn
why does that work again drug there is
no trickery I can whatever on my just
bring the bishop or anything like that
okay that's a good check oh yeah bishops
before tempting a threatening Borden's
made it sorted to keep made okay I get
it
that's nice okay yeah it's all bad I'm
such a tournament situation too and all
to play for such a trap I mean
especially if you don't risk anything if
I can actually switch there oops
what the heck I can switch there between
the views dig in you that I mean
chatroom doesn't make any sense during
the tournament okay Quinn to be six
yeah night sheets pops 93 I guess the
sidelines have to remember there's so
many good okay let's see what it's doing
here this'll Arjun wipes the development
here is fantastic
whoa hmm there are a couple of nice
choices I can also just develop further
take away the c7 square d5 also was
strong I think already yeah now g5 is
very very tempting again let's do it if
he takes my chase or pawn takes is both
good I mean I'm ahead like 40 empty and
development so I have to open everything
up it looks disastrous to threaten to
take on e6 and d6 that cannot be good
okay so I take here Bishop takes D take
c6 Bishop f4 details near that looks
devastating it sets more than there's
more than one thing I can do because the
take take is exit simple and likely also
winning quickly now that's actually
probably the cleanest choice maybe not
the quickest choice but very clean clean
takes will be one loses the Queen Queen
d1 I have an intermedia check on f7 and
Kim at this intermediate check and now I
have 95 coming and he's got no
development this is also very strong
attack even without Queens
as the Knights will jump to d5 and d5
and so on
now we have so we have go to a really
awful square ready for work th a trick
king of seven RAM and now whether there
is no immediate maid or something
unfortunately okay I can do the King go
with the chick chick and rupee one for
look e7 check Ruby seven chick and now
the ears is to just grab the bishop I
just wonder if I have an ID if I have a
maid
somewhere probably not so take them take
the material
yeah so like resigned 16th place slowly
catching up we gained in a couple of
points my Blitz rating is really
terrible here it wasn't good in the
first place but also that show many lost
two or three games recently due to
technical things we're tried you know
yesterday I tried to set this up and I
plan a joint tournament to check things
then I lost I think two games in the
process just basically by default anyway
so here we have a window paths with d6
g6 the sidelines that are sometimes
claimed let's see what Michele is doing
I am puts the bishop back oops
so bit surprising until voluntarily
retreats okay so how to do it here I
have a completely different idea than I
usually do but maybe maybe it's bonkers
but so don't wait go here and now push
a5 in the advance probably a bit shaky
this thing with I'm not sure how bad it
is yeah and both captures actually make
some sense with pawn takes is probably
the more aggressive one
yeah 94 words are taking you five but I
can push this forward and one thing
oh it's interesting allows me to take
here I know okay it's not a big deal
anyway
what I wanted to say is that he has very
little defense on a chem side very very
good I mean all the pieces are sitting
here okay but if I play a for me if I
can play a form that the tech is very
strong and how does he actually prevent
it like f4 95 f3 and so on it's
extremely dangerous okay yeah I'm just
threatening everything III 95
okay so III 93 just about holds so let's
bring this into the game and now I'm
simply threatening f43
I I don't really see any counter play
around here for maybe Queen g4 holes but
I can I can flick this in anyway
okay so now F 4 is strong f4 Queen g4 I
can also just retreat
or take on Gino take on g3 doesn't work
I would like to keep Queens on okay it
is strong it is strong anyway I can also
I can just trade and go and create a
route situ or something it's pretty
pretty awful when I would have preferred
to checkmate them but this is also
pretty pretty good can work g1 I mean as
of the take stuff maybe just take me too
we are here you three is the most
obvious choice probably also good so I
check here
so I'm just winning huge material here
yeah so here what is the biggest okay
just this is good take the knife and
then take care Loris also have a huge
time advantage
okay so I've actually gotten to the
first page then nine points behind just
promotion Alex just promotion Alex okay
but he also has some has two losses at
least own something could go wrong and I
don't really care so much about radios
my rating for example is just far too
low then okay the London system would be
three that didn't seem right with that
that looks pretty comfortable in just
took with the night any strengthens my
Center it's nice yeah whatever wonders
some some g6 he will play me play Bishop
e5 and then it's all very slow for him
but it looks playable
yeah yeah Gil 97th threatening each five
I think he should have done them it
should be five earlier okay I'm here
many moves I good I think this is one of
them trying to potentially click on the
three later especially if you go see
four that makes a lot of sense Kim and
now Bishop f5 is an idea maybe she like
five
so I want want to want to look really
not to give force at the point
maybe maybe 94 no but I got Bishop T Sam
doesn't try to do much definitely will
not trade this want to play five okay
that's a good Center enter Bishop am a
four is the next move I want to play
we just we can be three not quite sure
why what the compensation is
[Music]
f-for you but okay would be hb3 I mean
if this falls the whole Queen side is
totally breaking down even if even f5 is
an option but okay just taking cannot be
bad yeah here take c5 I'm sure I
understand but as I still still take all
this stuff and now now 94 maybe coming I
can go here time is still okay
hmmm that move I didn't really take into
account and was very stupid actually not
thinking about this okay let me take
this that's why I could done early on it
I thought my idea was better which it
wasn't
so we could take the apron off we are
still not an easy thing to do
so there's somewhat active I didn't see
that is a check okay it helps
13 seconds but all that difficult okay
so so five points behind maybe there are
still some challenges but okay another
minutes not a lot I can try to berserk a
game if I get a not super strong
opponent let's try that's not good
opening for berserk I mean it is not
good for white but it is murky sometimes
you just have to just have to calculate
stuff just really not what you want if
you're berserk in we just want to dash
out quick moves yeah like here does
abolition way you would like to think
for a moment and a blunder t54 no reason
at all
maybe after my opponent is just 1800 but
he will probably take stuff and I
blunder there it's looking good
that's so really what that's a pin you
know it looks just a check really
Nana doesn't real get off a white 93
chick
this is a double check this is also
check you can take everything here okay
come on white is running out of pieces
to sacrifice is this and take g6 next
okay okay
so that worked just one point behind now
oh okay people I'm scoring it other guys
get points as well so next one
yeah but the time I'm in the hunt here
this guy is okay that's not a good
position candidate probably with 2,300
yeah Thank You Bishop b2 is actually
correct but I don't I don't know the
theory maybe this is also correct it's
not saying it isn't but what is coming
here 94 94 Queen g3
interesting what is this doing Queen
here we do this and then he checks me
yeah maybe let's develop some stuff okay
where this is not bad that might be very
one-sided ending and I mean okay he's
got the bishop they are quite clearly
but but is it good for him okay Bishop
c3 Bishop f6 check naming keeping
keeping this on the board it doesn't do
that okay this is definitely a bit
better for white a bit or more than a
good even yeah just taking as good but
you can do this as well
you
yeah I actually would like to not treat
this as the bishop on your five is a
somewhat vulnerable piece on d5 like b54
it has no square so I don't just want to
take it yeah now I can maybe bring the
knight over to c5 yeah this is also a
helpful very good structure and it is a
look okay so all the nice one I like the
game
so I'm actually leading this at one
point but now I'm overtaken by Galvin so
verbally I'd like had aa and I get
pissed and he's buzzer King no I'm sorry
I just want this I just want to win the
game working you would be fun to do
funny decision to reserve okay so we
have the Squatch for night's game and
Jen like is playing one of the main
lines in this opening and probably will
take now no okay
interesting
hey ice playing this quite well even
even with the berserk Inge in effect and
I think I'm a little bit better than
this ending but again it's doing a good
job
okay so nineteen you cannot move this
easily 58 95 I think I'm getting a
little bit more Spacey Anders
okay this I'm stopping definitely who
came nanite b5 as an idea or just not to
phone
yeah but this is better for wide
interesting choice okay so I'm keeping
this
f six-membered he doesn't travel
so I've gone up but it's only it's not
easy at all
terrific okay so one need to push
forward with the King otherwise there's
no chance cooing okay so let's run the
coin
there's some way to do it you know this
is okay actually you need to come back
with my king to stop him from promoting
so okay yeah I was a kind of a funny
decision there to berserk I mean maybe
it would have been sporty but if I just
deserts as well on my end but I just
wanted to wanted to win the game and to
turn them and hopefully maybe someone
would takes me
yeah I don't know how this works the
atonement things are closed
I know somebody can theoretically
overtake me probably not yeah nice nice
end of this forum just the test test
tournament yeah I hope works fine the
whole thing
um yeah please I'm sent me feedback in
the comments what to possibly try to
improve I'm not quite sure maybe the
sound is a bit low I don't know it's a
bit difficult to to determine here also
with the very with the notebook speakers
and everything and okay thanks for
watching and I'm happy to hear your
feedback
bye bye